- Hey, guys, so we're in line
for our COVID-19 vaccines.
- Vaccination 2021.
- Shot number one.
- [Narrator] More and
more people are lining up
to get their COVID-19 vaccines.
Half of all US adults
have received at least one shot.
- Hey, guys, we're on the way to get.
- [Both] The second vaccine.
- Pfizer, so we'll keep you
posted on our side effects.
- How we're feeling after.
- [Narrator] As they do,
many are now also sharing
their side effects and some.
- I had a tiny headache
and a tiny little red spot
on my arm.
- [Narrator] Are more common than others.
- I don't know if you guys can see it,
there's a little bump right
above my left clavicle.
- [Narrator] So what side
effects should people expect
after getting their shots?
And when is it important
to seek medical attention?
- I can't really lift my
arm like past my shoulder
but that's it.
- [Narrator] Side effects like this,
pain and redness in the arm
where a person received their shot
are the most common.
Dr. Krutika Kuppalli says
they can even be a good sign.
- So the reason for the symptoms
is really because your immune system
is revving up to develop
those good antibodies
that you need to help
fight off the coronavirus
if you were to come into contact with it.
- So basically, it's like a training
for your immune system.
- Yeah, that's a really
good way to think about it.
- [Narrator] Headaches,
chills, fever, nausea,
body aches and in some cases,
even vomiting or diarrhea
are normal, if a bit unpleasant.
- I have been running to the bathroom.
I feel like my body's shutting down.
- [Narrator] People getting
the two-dose vaccines
from Pfizer and Moderna
may also feel different
from one dose to the next.
Many report feeling worse
after the second shot.
- Second COVID vaccine, the Pfizer shot,
has me in the bed.
- The second time you get the vaccine,
your body's already
experienced developing some
of the antibodies,
so your antibody response
is gonna be much higher
and so that's why those
symptoms you develop
are gonna be a bit stronger.
- [Narrator] But again,
this isn't everyone.
Doctors still don't have enough data
to say one dose carries
more severe side effects
than the other.
And whether the experience is different
for people who've had COVID.
- I was getting a little bit concerned
but I figured this was just
an enlarged lymph node.
- So some of the less common side effects
that we've seen of the vaccine
have been what we call lymphadenopathy
or enlarged lymph nodes.
- [Narrator] Though rare,
this swelling tends to happen
on the same side of the
body as the injection.
- It's a sign that your
immune system is working
and you might notice when you get a cough
or a cold, you get enlarged
lymph nodes in your neck.
- [Narrator] Also rare are cases
where patients have reported heart issues,
temporary paralysis to
one side of the face
or serious allergic reactions,
resulting in rashes and
difficulty breathing.
- This is one of the
reasons we have people wait
after they get their vaccine.
- [Nurse] Keep an eye on
you for 15 minutes, okay?
- [Woman] Okay.
- [Nurse] Between now and then,
if you feel anything outside ordinary,
please honk your horn.
I'll come over, take a look
and make sure you guys are okay.
- [Narrator] What's not normal
is having a runny nose,
cough or sore throat
after getting the vaccine.
- If you had those symptoms,
I would be worried that you had some sort
of upper respiratory infection
or possibly even COVID.
So I would recommend getting tested.
- [Narrator] Typically,
any side effect starts
to get better within a day or two
of getting vaccinated.
After that, Dr. Kuppalli recommends people
seek medical attention.
- Also if they have things
like difficulty breathing,
shortness of breath, swelling,
things that would be
considered emergencies.
- One of the more worrisome
adverse events reported recently
is a very rare type of blood
clot several women experienced
after getting the Johnson
& Johnson vaccine.
More than seven million people
in the US have gotten this vaccine.
- It really is one in a million people
that have had this event.
- For now, US regulators
have paused distribution of J&J's vaccine,
though Dr. Anthony Fauci
said he expects the vaccine
to return to use by the end of the week,
perhaps with additional
restrictions or warnings,
as was done in Europe.
What are some of the things
that people should do
in order to dampen their side effects?
- I would try to schedule time
to just kind of have a mellow day, right?
So you don't know how the
vaccine's gonna affect you.
- [Narrator] But Dr.
Kuppalli says don't worry
if you feel fine.
The vaccine is still working.
People over 55 typically
experience fewer side effects,
possibly because their immune
system gets weaker with age.
- I don't want people to think oh,
if I don't have a side
effect, that's a bad thing.
People's bodies are different as well.
- Don't be afraid to get the vaccine.
Everyone reacts differently.
Me and my sister did
not have any symptoms.
It doesn't mean you won't
but in the end, it's better than COVID.